since 2011 the number of abortion
clinics that have shut their doors has
skyrocketed 162 abortion providers have
either closed or stopped offering
abortions just 21 have opened right now
there are five states for just one
abortion clinic remains so what's
happened abortion opponents moved their
battleground from the picket line the
Statehouse testing how far abortion
rights could be limited without being
overturned and the Supreme Court
provided one answer in June so here's
the situation in 1973 the Supreme Court
in its landmark roe v wade case
legalized abortion in all 50 states
then in 1992 the High Court laid the
groundwork to undermine that ruling
it said states could pass restrictions
that don't present a quote undue burden
to women seeking an abortion
since then abortion opponents have been
testing just what undue burden means and
they found that legislation with
restrictions aimed at clinics have
proved more potent than past measures
aimed at patients like blockade and
clinics are mandating waiting periods
and parental notification the state of
Texas provides an excellent case study
and enacted a law forcing clinics to
meet hospital like surgical standards
and required abortion doctors to have
admitting privileges at local hospitals
that caused half of the state's clinics
to shut down and threaten to close
another ten or so if the law had been
fully implemented but in a 5-3 ruling
the Supreme Court struck down that law
saying it imposed that undue burden we
were talking about on a woman's
constitutional right to an abortion the
ruling is likely to doom similar
restrictions in other states in fact
just 24 hours later the High Court
turned away appeals from Wisconsin to
Mississippi to revive their doctor
admitting privileges now here's the
argument so how do abortion clinic
limits actually affect women
well almost half the six point seven
million pregnancies each year are on
pendant and almost half of those and
then abortion one study concluded that
of 31 states outlawed abortion tomorrow
the vast majority of women would still
travel to states where remained legal
however the impact on women who can't or
won't travel could result in a 15% drop
in abortions nationally there's also
evidence that diminishing access results
in more women resorting to dangerous and
illegal means to avert motherhood